[Music]
philip k dick begins his essay the
android and the human with this
wonderful sentence it is the tendency of
the so-called primitive mind to animate
its environment modern depth psychology
has requested us for years to withdraw
these anthropomorphic projections from
what is actually inanimate reality to
introject that is to bring back into our
own heads the living quality which we in
ignorance cast out onto the inert things
surrounding us and so we've got a
contrast set up here between different
kinds of mentalities different
viewpoints on the human being and the
environment and the things of their
environment do we look at the
environment in a way that analogizes
the things in it you know for example
machines or
lower animals as if they are human
they're animate in the same way that we
are having not just life but soul
or do we
regard that as dead inert although
movable programmable
matter that can be configured in
different ways and we are somehow
different from that or a third
possibility do we say
everything is basically
mechanism and you're going to notice
that as you read this essay
he talks about benedict spinoza
a you know great early modern
philosopher among other things he's also
a lens crafter
and spinoza is known for having not just
a pantheistic conception
of the universe and of substance but
also for being devoted to looking at
things in a mechanistic way including
the human passions including
our
intellect and spinoza is in certain
respects reflective of two of his great
predecessors to whom he's indebted
rene descartes
and thomas hobbes who
are at odds with each other on a number
of different things but especially
on the difference between the human
and the mechanism for thomas hobbes if
you ever read leviathan everything is
mechanistic everything is matter
including ourselves and our very own
minds
so we are he's got this kind of archaic
view the nerves are like you know little
cords that pull things back and forth
and we have gears and levers and things
like that going on in our brain
descartes on the other hand
looks at animals as being essentially
mechanisms our body as a very complex
mechanism so far in agreement with
hobbes but says that we have a mind or
soul
that is
radically distinct of a different kind
of order a different type of substance
than the body it's more closely
connected to than a
uh captain in his ship
um
but it's it's somehow distinct and
explaining how these get together
descartes has this whole theory about
the pineal gland that we don't need to
go into
here so this idea of distinctions
between human persons
and animals and machines
is something that has been with us for a
very long time
and as you know dick says to repeat this
sentence it is the tendency of the
so-called notice he's saying so-called
here primitive mind to animate its
environment um people view this as being
childish right introjecting the li the
life the anima into ourselves casting
out uh or no longer casting out this
onto the inner thing surrounding us is
said to be the mark of true maturity in
the individual and the authentic mark of
civilization in contrast to mere social
culture as one might find in a tribe and
then he says the native of africa is
said to view his surroundings as pulsing
with a purpose a life which is actually
within himself
once these childish projections are
withdrawn he sees that the world is dead
and that life resides solely within
himself or
other human beings right
and when he reaches this sophisticated
point he's said to be either mature or
sane or scientific so we've got this
interesting contrast here on the one
hand the childish the primitive the
atavistic mind over here right or it
could be the mind of our playing around
as well
on the other hand the mature scientific
attitude which realizes that these are
all just pipe dreams fantasies
perhaps insanity the real mature human
beings the well-developed ones have
science and that tells them about the
universe the world and we can realize
that our technology is just that
technology right
there's a danger here
as he points out in this very first
paragraph
one wonders
has he not also in this process reified
that is made into a thing other people
stones and rocks and trees may now be
inanimate for him but what about his
friends
has he not made them into stones too
this is indeed a
concern a worry a danger and it's a
greater danger than just for the
individual person as we're going to see
because it has to do with culture it has
to do with the determinative entities
and organizations within it
then dick goes on and he says there's a
new trend
and he says
the solution to this psychological
problem is of less importance than one
might think because
in the last decade and he's writing this
in the early 1970s we have seen a trend
not anticipated by our earnest
psychologists or by anyone else which
dwarfs that issue what is this problem
our environment
and i mean our
man-made world world of what
world of machines artificial constructs
computers electronic systems
interlocking homeostatic components
all this is in fact beginning more and
more to possess
what the earnest psychologists
fear
the primitive sees in his environment
animation
now
let's pause on this this word for a
moment because it's a very pregnant one
comes from you know uh anima or anamus
right there are two latin terms one of
which is typically used to mean mind
and involves affectivity
and um you know cognition the other
means soul and for the ancients the soul
is the principle of life
so things are animate when they have
some kind of soul when they are to use
some phrases self-move movers although
certainly able to be moved by other
things as well so
we are now and this is writing this
generations before the present beginning
to see in our environment animation in a
very real sense
he says
our environment is becoming alive or at
least
quasi-alive quasi
not entirely
kind of a facsimile
of it and this is presenting us with a
lot of problems and he says
it's becoming alive in ways specifically
and fundamentally analogous to ourselves
and then he brings up cybernetics and
norbert wiener
seeing valid comparisons between the
behaviors of machines and humans the
idea being that if we study machines
we will actually have valuable insights
into the nature of our own behavior by
studying what goes wrong with a machine
for example when two mutually exclusive
tropisms function simultaneously in one
of grey walters synthetic turtles
producing
fantastic fascinatingly intricate
behavior in the befuddled turtles we
learn perhaps a new
more fruitful insight into what humans
called neurotic behavior
so the idea is we study machines and we
get to learn more about how our own
minds and perhaps our minds and bodies
work together
but
dick suggests
this is where this is one of the very
important
aspects of this
maybe we need to turn the analogy
the other
way
he says
suppose a study of ourselves of our own
nature enables us to gain insight into
the now
extraordinarily complex functioning and
malfunctioning of mechanical and
electronic constructs in other words and
this is what i wish to stress and what
i'm saying here
it is now possible
we can learn about the artificial
environment around us how it behaves why
what it is up to by and notice this key
term here that's coming up over and over
again
analogizing
from what we know about ourselves
analogy analogizing the means of these
things are not exactly the same they're
not within the same classification
they're not to be reduced to each other
there is a dissimilarity in similarity
between them but there's enough
similarity there's enough points of
connection
that we can look at ourselves
and learn about these
machines that are becoming more and more
complex or
networks of these machines a little bit
later he's going to say and i think this
is a very important statement
our flight
must not only be to the stars but into
the nature of our own beings
because it is not merely where we go to
alpha centuries or to betelgeuse
but what we are as we make our
pilgrimages there our natures will be
going there too odd astra does to the
stars but per hominem as human being we
must never lose sight of that it would
after all be rather dismaying if the
first two-legged entity to emerge on the
surface of mars
from a terran spaceship were to declare
thanks be to god for letting me letting
me click letting click this is a
recording and then catch fire and
explode as a couple wires got crossed
somewhere in its plastic
chest right
so we may have
all sorts of things in front of us and
we could think about our
world that we live in today which is so
much more complexly
interfaced and interlaced with
technology than that
that even dick imagined
we still have to explore our human
nature and that allows us
to analogize from what we know
about ourselves
to make sense out of the machines and he
says machines are becoming more human so
to speak
at least in the sense that cybernetics
indicated some meaningful comparison
exists between human and mechanical
behavior but is it not ourselves that we
know first and foremost
rather than learning about ourselves by
studying our constructs
perhaps we should make the attempt to
comprehend what our constructs are up to
by looking into what we ourselves
are up to and the analysis that he's
going to provide here is attempting to
do this i think that you could say that
a lot of dick's fiction is also
similarly trying to do that as well
he goes on and he says perhaps
what we're seeing is a gradual merging
of the general nature of human activity
and function into the activity and
function of what we humans have built
and surrounded ourselves with
and he says a hundred years ago such a
thought would have been absurd
rather than merely anthropomorphic
note the difference between those absurd
means
it's not unthinkable because obviously
you can think absurd things but they do
they don't make sense you can't bring
them together
now we can say that that's just
anthropomorphic it's not absurd it could
make sense but it's wrong right
and he says uh what could a man living
in 1750 have learned about himself by
observing the behavior of a donkey steam
engine
and you know we could say
uh you know quite a bit we talked about
descartes and hobbs a little bit earlier
so maybe
dick is being a little bit bullish on
that and then he goes on and he says
i have in some of my stories of novels
written about androids or robots or
simulacra the name doesn't matter what
is meant is artificial constructs
masquerading as humans usually with some
sinister purpose in mind and then he
said i suppose i took it for granted if
such a construct a robot for example had
a benign or any how decent purpose in
mind it wouldn't have to disguise itself
now interestingly in a lot of these
stories
humans have disguised the android as a
human haven't they and then he goes on
and he says
this scene theme seems obsolete to me
the constructs do not
mimic
humans
right they're not imitating they're not
masquerading
they are in many deep ways actually
human already
they're not trying to fool us
for a purpose of any sort they merely
follow lines we follow
in order that they too may overcome such
common problems as the breakdown of
vital parts loss of power source
attacked by such foes as storms short
circuits
and and he goes on and then he says
um
we must reverse the analogizing of
cybernetics try to reason from our own
meditation and behavior to those of
machines
so
this suggests that maybe they are very
similar to us they could become
human
dick is actually not saying that and
then he's going to
give with one hand and take back with
the other and will probably meet
somewhere in between because he says
to assign purpose or motive to them
would be to enter the realm of paranoia
what machines do may resemble what we do
but they don't have intent in the sense
that we have now notice that he's not
saying
they don't have intent he's saying they
don't have intent in the sense that
we have they may have intent but it's
something kind of different they have
tropisms they have purpose
in the sense that we build them to
accomplish certain ends and react to
certain stimuli and here he gives the
example of a pistol a pistol is built
with the purpose of firing a metal slug
that will damage incapacitate or kill
somebody that doesn't mean the pistol
wants to do this and then he brings up
spinoza saying that if a falling stone
could reason it would say i want to fall
at the rate of 32 feet per second
and then he goes on and says free will
for us that is when we feel desire we
when we are conscious of wanting to do
what we do
may even be for us an illusion he's not
saying that it is an illusion
but depth psychology seems to say many
of our drives originate from an
unconscious that's beyond our control we
are driven
as are insects although the term
instinct is not applicable
for us so this is interesting we've got
two sides right the machines becoming
more and more sophisticated more and
more invested with human purposes and
you know uh ideas becoming more like us
and on the other hand we have us who can
always be
kind of like machines or insects and
we're you know understanding through
modern humanities and science
that perhaps our
realm of you know conscious
decision-making is a little bit narrower
than we
present it to ourselves right
and then he talks about a thought
not too pleasing
here's what he's suggesting
as the external world becomes more
animate
we may find that we the so-called humans
are becoming
and may to a great extent always have
been inanimate in the sense that we are
led
directed by built-in tropisms rather
than leading
so we and our elaborately evolving
computers may meet ourselves
half may meet each other
halfway
and he frames it in terms of an
antagonistic situation someday a human
being named perhaps fred white may shoot
a robot named pete something or other
which has come out of a general
electrics factory into his surprise yet
weep and bleed and the dying robot may
shoot back and to its surprise see a
whiff of gray smoke arise from the
electric pump that it supposes mr
white's bleeding heart it would be a
great moment of truth for both of them
so this leads him to ask them well what
is authentically
human the other thing that he talks
about that is quite important with all
these implications is
this is not just an abstract uh
conversation about the possibilities of
artificial intelligence and human beings
because it is possible for human beings
to be reduced to the android and a lot
of processes and organizations
within
modern
culture
are trying to do that
to human beings so it's important to
resist
androidization the reduction to the
ultimately
inanimate animated but not animate
so this is where he begins this address
setting us a very interesting
problem
and a proposal let's look at ourselves
if we want to understand what's going on
with machines
you